As California taxpayers, you invest in UCLA.
So, we thought you'd like to know what happens to your money.
UCLA is world-renowned for teaching, research, and service, and its healthcare enterprise
is one of the nation's best.
With 45,000 students and 43,000 full and part-time
employees, UCLA is a big university.
Among our staff and alumni, you'll find 14
Nobel laureates, 13 MacArthur fellows,
nine National Medal of Science winners.
Not to mention Pulitzer Prize, Oscar, Emmy and Golden Globe Award recipients.
UCLA was ranked the top public institution by U.S. News & World Report, and the best value by Forbes.
One-third of our students are first in their
families to go to college.
We have high transfer rates and offer supportive
programs so Californians can be successful and graduate.
Where else does your money go?
Well, right back into the California economy.
During 2016-17, UCLA's economic impact on the California economy was $11.06 billion.
UCLA supported over 72,700 full-time jobs
in California.
24 startups were formed using UCLA technology,
creating more jobs and encouraging more spending.
Since 2000, startup valuations built on UCLA's
tech total $33 billion.
This is all not to mention that the college
degree earned by its students will help them
make more money in their lifetimes, adding
to California's growth since most UCLA students
remain in the state.
We're grateful for every dollar received,
and hope that you see that an investment in
UCLA pays dividends to all of us in the City
of Los Angeles, Southern California, and across
the great state of California.